a new host is joining us here on the
talks
starting next monday
but we couldn't wait to share the news
so she's popping in right now let's give
a big talk welcome to natalie morales
hi guys
so natalie we all spoke uh with you over
the weekend and we're so excited to
welcome you here with us
thank you cheryl
i gotta say it was the warmest welcome
you guys have embraced me with such open
arms and i love chatting with each of
you um as you all know i had an
incredible relationship almost as long
as i've been married i've been married
23 years i was at nbc for 22 years so i
had a wonderful time there but it's
always exciting and new to you know
start something different and and i love
this new adventure that we're all going
to be taking together
all right so
no
no go ahead i'm sorry you go ahead we
we are so excited to have you i mean i
you know it's not only us if you read
the interwebs this weekend i mean
everyone was you're you're you're
beloved everywhere but i have to say
this weekend you know i said you were
joining the show and i have two 12 year
old daughters and they went immediately
to your instagram page and um
they uh they seem to take a liking to
your son luke who i think is over your
left shoulder right there who is about
13. yes they were commenting i guess
that pic no this picture that was him
when he was a baby this picture is him
uh yeah still as a young child but now
he's a very handsome teenager i have to
say
are you over here trying to make a
little matchmaker here listen i will say
as in in natalie's world i think they
call this a developing story
yes it is very true and i'm glad that he
has
[Laughter]
i just wanted to say to all of you um
you know i've been a huge fan i've been
watching all of you as you all have been
soaring on this show cheryl i've been on
there a couple of times with you and you
always just made me feel so welcome and
such a part of the team so i can't wait
to sit next to you
amanda what you have been through has
shown us all how to inspire
and seeing you now soar there on the
talk and also on dancing with your fox
trot last week amazing the highest score
i can't wait to see your cha-cha this
week
and and i know um jerry i remember you
dancing on top of a table last time you
were on access hollywood with us so
i look forward to more dancing on the
table
you know what i'll tell you what i'm
looking for
yeah we go way back in fact we were
actually in tokyo during the olympics
and we spent uh a good amount of time
together there 23 days out there and uh
i do have to tell this funny story like
you guys know i love to work out and i'm
getting ready to you know hit my
workouts oh natalie you know we should
get a workout and she's like yeah let's
get a workout in and my buddy matt
eisenmann pulls me over and says akbar
do not work out with her i'm telling you
it's a trap he's like she was saying
yeah let's just go for a little jog and
before you know it you're 20 miles in
and i'm like i was like all right so
then every time i saw every time i saw
you in the hallways i'd be like
yeah we're gonna get that workout in
we're gonna get that workout
all right well now no wonder you avoid
it together
we are very excited about you coming but
i will not be working out with you
natalie i will work out with you don't
you worry i will be your buddy
now and i just really wanted to say like
it's gonna be so wonderful to have you
here i think that you have been such an
example for women on tv especially the
hosting platform you are always such a
light no matter what you're doing your
smile is so gracious and inviting and i
think we are so lucky to have you a part
of this team here on the top
thank you
natalie i'm really excited that we have
one more vote for the ladies it's me you
i'm panda voting against these two
fellas right here in the conversation
well just like in sports this is our
basketball squad so we got good we got
our starting five here and so i'm i'm
looking forward to this
i'll play the center by the way i'm the
center yeah
i like it i like it but it's gonna be a
fun team yeah it was so nice to speak
with you and uh
to
welcome you to our family and and i
really want to say to the world
this
host uh configuration
represents what the nation looks like
that's great
that was right
and i think we're gonna have some great
conversation and i'm just so happy that
you are coming to play with us and have
fun with us and bring some great
conversation because the talk
is the great destination for great
congressmen
yes boys
puerto rico puerto rico
you'll have to teach me some more
spanish but natalie on behalf of
everyone here at the talk we can't wait
to have you here in studio with us next
monday so it is going to be all and
popping when you get here
congratulations again and we'll see you
next monday
[Applause]
[Music]
you